foreign
's portrait is on every single note of
remin B the Chinese currency and so
really what we are seeing is a
glorification of a mass murderer because
nobody in history has killed more people
matter of fact the person who's in
second place is not even close so
clearly this is wrong for the People's
Republic to keep his image on the
currency but the fact that they do is a
real indication of how they feel foreign
ERS party is very careful about what it
teaches the Chinese people about Mao
Zedong he is the hero of the People's
Republic he's the one who's considered
to establish the Republic in 1949 who
won the Chinese Civil War and so I think
most Chinese people view him as a hero
his great excesses his failures and his
killing of Chinese people is something
that people really don't know very much
about if they know anything at all
if Germany put Hitler on the currency
there would be outrage around the world
it would be white hot and we know this
because when people around the world
actually adopt Nazi symbols
um there is uh not only criticism
um but there is this outrage as there
should be
um but when China puts miles to talk on
the currency
no big deal no one thinks about it
most crimes were different for instance
from Hitler's
um Mal I actually killed tens of
millions of people just through
recklessness gross negligence he had to
know what was going on but he continued
these abnormal policies and that is
considered to be different than for
instance Mass extermination which is
Hitler's crime
um so there's that difference but also I
think that leftist murderers seem to get
a pass and there are a number of reasons
for it but I think that part of it is
because there is a leftist bet in much
of the media so people are able to
justify Mao saying oh he was just an
idealist going wrong well no he wasn't
because we know that the things that he
did he had to know that tens of millions
of people were being killed by his
policy decisions so this has gone beyond
I think idealism it was recklessness it
was murderous it was wrong and and in
any event he spilled more blood than any
other human in history so therefore he
shouldn't get a pass even if he had the
best of intentions and by the way his
intentions were not good Mao was a
communist and Xi Jinping the current
ruler very much reveres Mao and I
believe would take China in the same
direction he's already moving China
towards full-on totalitarianism we're
seeing a Resurgence of State Enterprises
and state institutions so that's the
direction that Seas taking China and so
as long as Siege and big is around Mao's
going to remain on the currency
[Music]